bonsoir mesdames et messieurs ce qui ne
devait être qu'une simple journée de
travail s'est transformé en drame ce
midi sur l'estacade du pont champelin
j'y retrouve jacques Bissonnet Jacques
un travailleur est tombé dans le fleuve
et les recherches pour le retrouver
n'ont rien donné qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
exactement alors c'est survenu un peu
aprèsmidi aujourd'hui alors le
travailleur était sur une plateforme
temporaire situé sous les sacades alors
je vous montre immédiatement des images
en direct de ce qui reste de cette
plateforme donc qui pend actuellement
entre l'estacade et les EAU du fleuve
donc le travailleur était là-dessus et
c'était soutenu tout ça par quatre bloc
chaînes et vraisemblablement selon la
police c'est que un des blockchain a
cédé précipitant donc le travailleur
dans les eaux du fleuve al évidemment
les recherches ont immédiatement été
entreprise on a tenté de le sauver
d'ailleurs par des travailleurs qui
étaient juste à côté mais en vain alors
il y avait des pompiers de Longueil de
Montréal les policiers de Montréal
policier la Sûreté du Québec également
la Garde côtière il y a même eu
l'hélicoptère de la Sûreté du Québec à
certain moment qui a survolé les lieux
alors évidemment c un accident de
travail la CSST était dépêché sur les
lieux deux inspecteurs vont rencontrer
on nous a dit de 4 à 5 témoins pour
tenter de comprendre ce qui a pu se
passer mais la question que tout le
monde se pose est-ce que ce travailleur
portait oui ou non un harnet de sécurité
et ou un gilet de sauvetage alors on ne
le sait pas voici la CSST
là-dessus ça dépend à quelle étape des
travaux donc pour l'instant on connaît
pas l'information à savoir si le
travailleur avait unnet de sécurité ou
non euh à cette étape-là des travaux oui
unnet sécurité qui doit être porté
puisque les gardescps sont
retirés à Patrice évidemment les travaux
sur l'estacade et aussi sur le pont
champelin qui est juste à côté ont été
interrompus pour la journée bien sûr et
il y avait des travailleurs qui étaient
ramené sur sur la rive ils étaient
plutôt plutôt découragés secoués par ce
qui est arrivé aujourd'hui voici
quelques
réactions il ça qu'il VI une charge puis
le tril lâché parce que c'était c'est
trop l'au fait ça donne un coup sa
plateforme la plateforme à tomber ben on
a été un peu sensibilisé avec qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé puis en même temps ben
ça nous fait prendre conscience
que la sécurité c'est important surtout
sur enous d'un pont et on va Jacques
même si le courant est extrêmement fort
là on le sait on va poursuivre les
recherches jusqu'à quand c'est ce qu'on
nous dit on va poursuivre les recherches
ce soir jusqu'à la tombée de la nuit en
fait jusqu'à l'arrivée de de la noirur
mais j'ai vu tout à l'heure un camion
avec de l'éclairage je sais pas ce que
ça veut dire il a la Sté du Québec est
sur place souci et la question aussi
qu'on se pose parce que les recherches
se concentent autour de l' escacade
plutôt alors est-ce qu'il y a piqué au
fond de l'eau parce que évidemment les
travailleurs ont un équipement assez
lourd sur eux des bottes avec en en en
ciment en béton plutôt alors ça peut
être enfin on sait pas où le courant est
très fort vous l'avez signalé est-ce qui
était emporté on verra jacqu y en a trop
de ces accidents on se quitte avec des
chiffres c'est en 2014
82 300 21 travailleurs victime d'un
accident de travail et parmi ces
accidentés 57 qui ont perdu la vie ben
voilà merci Jacques je vous pris au
revoir